[Musique]
le troisième lien entre Québec et Lévis
est au centre de la campagne électorale
depuis plusieurs jours et contrairement
à ce que François le goût affirme la
croissance démographique anticipée est
loin d'être un argument en faveur de ce
projet qui dévaluer à 6 milliards et
demi de dollars selon les projections de
l'Institut de la statistique du Québec
mise à jour le 25 juillet dernier la
population active dans la région
métropolitaine de Lévis va diminuer de
600 personnes d'ici 2031 10 années plus
tard 2041 elle n'aura grimpé que de 1700
personnes on va se pencher sur ce sujet
avec Fanny Tremblay rasticot et les
professeurs adjointe à l'École nationale
d'administration publique bonsoir madame
Tremblay rassicot
bonsoir madame Saint-Arnaud évidemment
il y a toutes sortes de facteurs qui
entrent en ligne de compte quand on
planifie des projets de transport des
projets de transport en commun
développement du réseau routier à quel
point la démographie c'est un facteur
qui est important dans ce calcul
mais généralement traditionnellement la
manière dont planifie les projets de
transport c'est avec le modèle qu'on
appelle predict temporide donc on prédit
la croissance démographique et on
travaille on donne on offre le service
en fonction de ses projections
démographiques là ça c'est les modèles
traditionnels maintenant ce qu'on
regarde si on suit les modèles
traditionnels la démographie le justifie
tout simplement pas mais de toute façon
la démographie ça a pas été le premier
argument pour mettre de l'avant le
projet 3e lien si on remonte on fait un
peu l'historique du projet la raison
pour laquelle c'est revenu en avant plan
c'était en 2015 lorsque les différents
paliers de gouvernement provincial
fédéral municipal se chicanais
concernant la facture de la peinture du
fond du Québec là le projet de troisième
lien est revenu en avant-plan après ça
ça a été une question de congestion sur
les ponts après ce qu'on a vu que
c'était pas trop le cas le la congestion
sur les ponts elle est bien gérée
ensuite de ça c'est la sécurité ensuite
de ça l'autre argument qu'on a mis de
l'avant c'est le droit au développement
puis là on est rendu avec maintenant la
démographie on a vu que c'est pas un
facteur puis on cherche un peu là on dit
il va y avoir un chantier de la dévie à
des vies et tout ça donc on cherche des
raisons pour justifier le projet mais
parmi les arguments qui sont soulevés
effectivement
entre autres l'idée
ça encouragerait un dynamisme
entrepreneurial c'est ce que prétend en
tout cas le maire de Lévis François
Legault est-ce que vous y croyez
d'attractivité dans le corridor Montréal
Québec ce qui est particulier d'ailleurs
dans les projections entre autres qu'on
a eu de l'ISQ on dit que d'ici 2041 les
personnes de 65 ans et plus vont
représenter c'est plus de la moitié
c'est 58 % de la croissance
démographique de la région de Québec
c'est pas une population active c'est
pas des gens qui utilisent leur voiture
est-ce qu'il faut prendre en compte cet
aspect là dans le calcul à savoir ce
qu'on va de l'avant ou non avec le
troisième lien
je crois que oui puis c'est la
localisation du des projections est
importantes aussi donc en ce moment là
le grand déplacement Rive-Nord et Sud se
fait à partir de la Rive-Sud vers la
Rive-Nord ce qu'on regarde dans les
tendances c'est que c'est la croissance
sur la Rive-Nord qui va être le plus
importantes sur la Rive-Sud la
croissance qui va se faire d'ici 2041
c'est une population de 65 ans et plus
et qui a tendance à moins se déplacer
donc si on regarde aussi le avec le
télétravail dès qu'on libère de l'espace
dès qu'il y a une augmentation de la
capacité routière ça c'est repris par la
demande croissante la demande induites
en transport on le voit dans la grande
région de Montréal en ce moment
le retour au travail il y a énormément
de congestions des niveaux de congestion
qui dépassent les niveaux prépendémiques
puis il y a une chute dans le transport
collectif de 30%. donc lorsque dès que
de la nouvelle espace du nouvel espace
qui se libère c'est compensé par la
croissance de la demande pour François
Legault est revenu quand même à la
charge hier peu importe les conclusions
des études sur le troisième lien ce sera
personnel à cadre voix qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
j'en pense que c'est un choix politique
puis ce que ça laisse penser c'est que
peu importe si c'est une bonne décision
d'un point de vue d'investissement de
sainte gestion des fonds publics
environnementales peu importe on va
aller de l'avant quand même je pense que
on peut s'attendre
de mieux de nos décideurs qui a ça et la
place du transport en commun madame
tremblerasico on dit deux voies
réservées aux autobus aux heures de
pointe est-ce que c'est assez
en fait il y a même pas de bonne
capacités de bons transports collectifs
sur les ponts existants ni sur les
points existants ni sur la Rive-Nord et
la Rive-Sud donc je pense qu'on peut
très bien utiliser les ponts existants
et améliorer la traverse Québec les vies
parce que ce qui est important c'est de
faire traverser les la population les
gens et non pas les véhicules c'est
évidemment c'est très très politique ce
sujet là on se le cachera pas mais
est-ce qu'on a maintenant vous
considérez là toutes les données
nécessaires pour prendre les bonnes
décisions
non je pense pas je pense qu'il aurait
fallu de 1 à avoir un plan de transport
régional on en a pas parce que Québec au
plat a pas d'autorité régionale de
transport ce qui est dans le plan
métropolitain d'aménagement de
développement on le pas mis en oeuvre ça
fait 10 ans qui était adopté puis les
mesures qui ont qui sont inscrites au
PMA pour le l'aspect transport
interagénaire ou intérêt a pas été mis
de l'avant puis le bureau de projet
lorsque été mise en place en 2018
identifier 5 corridors donc il a été mis
en place par le gouvernement précédent
deux corridors dans l'Ouest un quart
d'heure au centre et deux correcteurs
dans l'est et c'est étudiant à ne jamais
été complétée donc si il y a vraiment
une nécessité mais cette étude là aurait
permis de le dire et puis aurait permis
de dire aussi qu'elle est la meilleure
option pour se déplacer donc tant qu'on
n'a pas une étude indépendante faite par
une autorité compétente et apolitique on
le repas
la vraie solution madame tremblerasco
merci beaucoup pour votre analyse ce
soir
je vous en prie au revoir